- Ready to go?
OK.
We look for any contraband,
agricultural products,
narcotics, money, instruments
of terror, anything like that
prohibited from
the United States.
So this morning we had an
express consignment flight
arrive from Germany.
What we're going to
be doing is we're
going to utilize our
canine, and we're
physically going to
inspect the packages
and see what we come up with.
Guys, let's just lay these
out in a straight line.
We have to work quickly,
because a lot of the packages
are overnight or
two-day shipping.
So we have only a short
time before they need
to arrive at their destination.
All right, bring him in.
- Bach is trained
on narcotics-- meth,
ecstasy, heroin, cocaine,
marijuana and hash,
and now fentanyl.
[whistles]
An alert on his
package right here.
- Let's take, take it
out, let him keep going.
- That's a good boy.
Good boy.
[whistles] All right, good boy.
Good to go.
- We'll do an exam on
this table over here.
Looks like we've
got two toy cars.
A little bit of weight to it.
Bingo!
Feels like pills.
- All right, let's take a look.
- And yes, pills--
square pills, different colors.
- We don't know what it is.
Until we get a field test,
we don't know what it is.
- We have a positive
response for ecstasy.
The total weight is 114 grams.
These pills look like Pez candy.
A child gets a hold of
them, and one pill ingested
could be a fatal, a fatal dose.
We'll wrap it up.
We'll make the phone
call the HSI, which
is our investigative unit.
And they will find out
who's ordering this,
who's distributing
this, and ultimately we
want to put them in jail.